why are you doing this so I think one
it's it's you're exactly right usually I
say it's the company but this time at
least for now it's actually my personal
share my personal cash that that's
rolling this this program out but it
really is for the betterment of the
employees when I came to this country or
my parents came we came from a very
humble background and so education was
really the trajectory changer for me at
least and I see the folks that work in a
warehouse and around the office and if
you're not able to afford college
tuition for your kids which is
ever-expanding in terms of price how can
you ever make that change for your
families and so that's really the
genesis of it what is this gonna mean
for your company's bottom line so
luckily I think it was very easy for the
board to approve because it was actually
my personal bottom line so so in a sense
the Wong family bottom line my wife was
a little you know but she was very
supportive of it but I think morale
around the company is obviously a boost
it but also I would say the dedication
of our team members now is that much
more kind of prevalent I have to ask you
because you know you've been hearing
these horror stories of people who have
been burdened with student debt and
they're not paying it back until their
30s 40s and in some instances their 50s
did that factored into your thinking
absolutely just a little bit really I
think when I go back to the the real
kind of reason why we did it was
actually some of our folks when we first
started fulfillment centers in certain
areas they couldn't even you know for
cars for themselves and we were thinking
that if you're not able to do that then
how are you able going how are you ever
gonna be able to afford thirty five
fifty thousand dollars a year for for
your children and if they're not going
to college the many generations down the
line they're not gonna go as well and so
that was the real kind of factor that
that got got me to do it one night I
would imagine I don't know this but I
would imagine that the reaction from the
employees was ranged from overwhelming
joy yes absolutely so there were
definitely some peers around the room
and mine included a little bit but also
there was funniest people some people
pretty snarky they were like how drunk
did you get last night and so luckily I
you know I was completely sober when I
thought about it but in general there
was just pure you lations around the
room I think what did education mean for
you
life and for your family's life I
wouldn't be here talking to market if I
wasn't wasn't educated I think if I
didn't have access to higher education I
wouldn't have had those doors available
to me I know every path is different but
I just can only judge from my own path
that that was so transformative for for
me in my life there gonna be any
parameters state school versus private
so definitely not parameters in terms of
which school you can go to because I
don't want to fetter you this is about
you getting the education you want and
deserve so definitely know like you know
if you're going to go to MIT then I
don't want to say we're not gonna pay
for MIT go to Community College you know
and so for us it's across the board the
only thing we don't cover his room and
board so it'll be tuition only so if you
can't afford it now you'll also have to
work a little bit in college to to to
pay for room and board what's this going
to do to your retention rate do you
think well it's funny because we had
certain employees who are married with
kids their wives kind of text in
afterwards you're never allowed to ever
leave this company so it increases my
retention rate because I have to make
good on this and so I'll be at least
forever with the company um what do you
see this growing divide now between the
haves and have-nots specifically in the
technology world that's you've seen this
huge dichotomy right like technology as
a sector I mean you guys cover a lot in
your show mark and so it's booming by
all accounts right but but you're really
seeing a dichotomy of folks that that
are riding that way but also people that
are getting left behind and and for us
especially I consider myself the leader
of our company and within technology one
of the leaders within our company and in
their overall technological field we
really have to give back in order to
make sure that does not happen so in a
sense here what we're having is you
making a statement and hoping that other
CEOs will follow it have you gotten
calls from other CEO I write some of our
investors actually were rather inspired
and that they wanted to put their own
personal money into the program as well
but I have heard some of the other CEOs
have emailed me hey how does the program
work and and there there actually has
been a few emails that have come across
my inbox I'm stunned by this I remember
when I saw this but it gets the bottom
line for you is that education will make
the difference and without it your life
will be poor
for it poorer in many ways not only just
educationally but perhaps financially as
well so not just you but also
generations sure if you fast forward and
that's the main point of it